okay here we Beck are we back are well
one of you let her every lie it's a
selfie on the speaking for Yoda yeah Tim
Gunn what was it like for your father
working with J Edgar Hoover in the FBI
yes I read that in your book your father
worked in the FBI and you have some
interesting stories about there for 26
years he was he was an agent but he was
primarily Hoover's ghostwriter he wrote
his books and his speech of agent
provocateur yes right but have you heard
my yes racy store oh I'd like to to tell
it to everyone
well just briefly on my sister and I
were big I Love Lucy fans and we would
visit dad at his office once a year and
take the FBI tour was a big Washington
thing and one day we were there and dad
said would you like to meet Vivian Vance
F Wayne F emerge who wouldn't want to
meet Vivian Vance Ethel Mertz so we went
into Hoover's office and met her and she
was gracious and wonderful and many
years later and my father was gone a lot
came out about Hoover cross-dressing a
lot um and it was all very interesting
my mother didn't believe any of it and
said rightfully so this would have
killed your father I probably would have
but when it came out I said to my sister
don't you think it's a little strange
that mr. Hoover wasn't in the office
with Vivian Vance
I mean put a fright wig on them but but
of all the people if you weren't
cross-dressing why would you dress as
vivian Venge wouldn't you want to do it
somebody more glamorous 22 I mean
remover looked a bit like an English
Bulldog so sorry apologies the Vivian
bands right but what's interesting is
Simon & Schuster's legal team
investigated everything in this book and
they looked into this and they talked to
bid the advances to biographers who had
never heard or knew about a visit to the
FBI then they checked the visitor logs
no Vivian Vance did your father know
this or you know Fred I'll never know
I'll never know
but you have theories that maybe your
father was I think my father was such a
homophobe I'm confident he was a closet
case and I think that may have been true
of all the up of the upper echelon of
the bureau is a very interesting
collection of men michelle has gone so
well up Bret Stevens what do you think
of Harvard's decision to hire Chelsea
Manning as a visiting fellow and then
they would throw up the artwork through
the offer today hmm yeah that's a loaded
question
visiting hello what well yeah it was
advisor up to talk yeah yeah the boys
are off to give it oh just to give my
speech yeah I don't think the invitation
should have been issued but once it was
issued it certainly shouldn't have been
rescinded I think that is you think
Chelsea Manning's a traitor
well I think Bradley Manning put a lot
of human beings in danger by what he did
by his disclosures I don't even think
that's debatable but Bradley Chelsea
Manning spent seven years in prison his
sentence was commuted by the President
of the United States he's free she's
free and she should be able to live her
life and if Harvard wants to invite her
and hear from her just not today should
hear I mean I think the whole business
of dis invitation is a sickness in this
country I agree hearing people is a
precondition afford for being able to
disagree with it and also that everybody
has to be fired the second you don't
like one thing they said right they
certainly go after me with this it
happened to you when you went to the New
York Times this this the the White House
is asking for this ESPN reporter to be
fired there's no other problems in the
country right you know or the world the
world is a placid Eden so he can
concentrate on this I know but it's not
just him I mean everybody seems to go
immediately to you have to disappear
altogether if I don't like one thing you
said ever as opposed to what we used to
do which is just oh I didn't like that
what's on the other channel I had some
experience of people wanting me to
disappear forever
and you won all right friend
so far knock on wood okay besides New
York are there any American cities you'd
describe as great Chicago
yeah it looks good I mean Chicago is the
only other American see that feels
really like a city to me you know I mean
there are you know San Francisco it's
adorable little town la is very spread
out have you know any feeling of density
but Chicago really feels like a city I
like Chicago you're not really saying
that LA is lacking in intellectualism is
it because that that is such a know I
was saying it's never densely populated
it's spreading that's what we like about
it that's what I like exactly but it
doesn't feel like a city it's not urban
because it's not but it's not dense
enough right for it to be it's just not
normal to live in a building you know I
don't care how nice your apartment is I
always known this somebody on the other
side of that wall and they're farting
and cooking and it's just wrong I'd
rather live in the shittiest little
single dwelling house than live in a
building but in houses outside ex
murderers
and no doorman Sal what is the antidote
to political correctness on college
campuses axe murderers yeah the antidote
is to ignore it and to get and to speak
severely to people who want to propagate
right you know and I mean I have to say
in my experience of the American Academy
which is now getting on for 20 years I
have never had a student say to me that
he wanted a trigger warning or a she
wanted a safe space or you know I've
never had it I hear that it happens
around the country right I have no
personal experience of it so I don't
know how much of this there is but you
know what's missing I think is
leadership I think too much of too many
campus administrators are basically
cowed yes by small minorities of
totalitarian minded students we just
don't want to hear anything except what
they're disposed to agree with right and
the job of grown-ups is to behave like
grown-ups and say know intellectually a
college is not a safe space yeah
intellectually a college is it going to
be place where your ideas are harmed and
perhaps even destroyed and that's as it
should be
[Applause]
[Music]
the college should be a safe space for
thought yes right not not a safe space
from Fort right and if you go to college
and you never hear anything you haven't
thought before or then you know you may
as well have stayed home right and
people who think that they should never
hear things they've that would upset
them should go somewhere else and leave
that space available to somebody who can
benefit from what is called education
part of my responsibility to be to
provoke inshallah absolutely that's what
a teacher does okay does the backlash
against Hillary's book have anything to
do with sexist attitudes about women
expressing anger express is she
expressing anger a lot of men telling
her to shut up
you know or men explaining what she did
wrong in the first six months
men were cause I think here's what
Hillary Clinton did wrong right you know
and it just enraged me because Donald
Trump didn't win because he did
something right he won because he did
something wrong yes I didn't know there
was a big back that clash against rebuff
by every politician winner or loser
writes a damn book right exactly a six
million dollars of the book sell for
copies yeah
publishers think this is worth it right
you know I mean I want to know how that
happens I'd like to be paid six million
dollars for books that sell for copiers
alright but I said it last week I'll say
it again I think future historians will
be just so puzzled why so many people in
America found Hillary Clinton to be this
polarizing I mean I could see why you
wouldn't vote for her you wouldn't vote
for unless it's a Donald Trump right you
mean you write the situation you
wouldn't have you know McCain or Mitt
Romney I mean there's nobody else in the
Republican Party practically you could
probably think no on the contrary oh
really
I could never voted for a guy like Mike
Pence really yeah you
going through Hillary over Mike Pence
yeah probably you are my hero but the
problem with the difference between
Trump and Pence is that Trump is an
authentic fraud right and Pence's in a
sense exactly the opposite he's a
fraudulent authentic you don't you know
and when Pence sort of attests to
Donald's goodness as a man and you know
he doesn't believe a word but he's
saying this with this kind of pious
oleaginous fake sincerity right it's
terrible because you know he knew with
Trump you never know that he knows that
he's lying but he's right because
there's always the interface of the the
manic personality disorders but Pence is
a man in his right mind yes and that's
why he's horrible is that I've seen Mike
Pence before you're right he's a typical
arch conservative Christian hypocrite
and we've seen them before and to use
your phrase it's a survivable event I
could do - but you asked me whether I
would vote for him yes whether he's a
survival no I'm very surprised to hear
you say that is there anybody else you
think I'm on the right who you would
prefer Hillary Clinton to ben Carson
Mike Huckabee Mike Huckabee Wow I don't
like this hyper pious 'no sin Republican
politics I mean the Republican Party
in a dream world the Republican Party
would stand for aspiration opportunity
and inclusion Democrats that's know
that's what it should be especially on
the aspiration front it is a right to
rise party now we can have an argument
right perfectly sensible whether there
are solutions are right but it's
aspirational it means going from lower
middle class to upper class from Joni
Ernst to Senator someone else's
Christian piety done my Jewish throat is
not kosher well it's not going to happen
tonight
[Applause]